this tiny robot may look unassuming but
even at a mere 100 grams about as heavy
as a bar of soap the fly crow tug can
pull up to 40 times its own weight to
create the mighty fly crow tug named for
its flying micro tugging features
researchers took a cue from wasps
typically these insects use their
stinger to subdue prey before
transporting it back to their nest the
prey is too heavy to fly with some wasps
plant their feet on the ground and pull
their prey home similarly when a payload
is too heavy for flight anything bigger
than the robot itself the fly crowed tug
stays on terra firma where it uses
adhesives and tiny metal hooks called
micro spines to stick to a surface and a
powerful tether to tug on an object the
researchers demonstrated the fly crow
tugs capabilities by anchoring it atop a
partially collapsed building and having
it haul up a bulky set of sensors to
inspect small openings in the rubble
flat crow tugs can also work together to
open doors one pulls the handle
downwards while sticking to the door
itself and another pulls the door open
while anchored to the ground the fly
crow tug still has room for improvement
it's 5-minute flight time limits the
robots to only short-range operations
and more difficult multi-step tasks
require more than one fly crow tug still
fly crow tugs unprecedented strength
gives it an advantage over other
miniature drones which due to their size
can typically only survey their
environment instead of actually
interacting with it that could make this
new class of robots useful and
everything from planting sensors and
hard-to-reach spots to removing debris
in disaster zones
[Music]
[Music]